ya mira voy a mostrarte algo ya eres
casi un estudiante como cualquier otro
hoy me dieron mi diplomas delf de 10
es un diploma de estudios en lengua
francesa su primer diploma francés
espera seguir mejorando mi nivel de
lengua francesa con jose
a este joven sirio lo entrevistamos a su
llegada a francia tres años atrás en ese
entonces no hablaba una sola palabra de
francés y contaba en un inglés precario
el horror de la guerra
[Música]
ese día las fuerzas del régimen atacaron
a los civiles
mataron 32 personas sólo sobrevivió este
bebé
hoy compartir su historia con los
jóvenes de todo el país
ella desde sucesión en un contacto de
asociaciones universidades y liceos me
contactaron para que les inste la
conferencia
para compartir mi experiencia y mi
trabajo con los estudiantes
para responder a algunos estudiantes me
han dicho es interesante que cuenta
porque es algo que nos da la información
la tele
schaer sólo tenía 15 años cuando estalló
la batalla de alguien su casa fue
destruida por los bombardeos informaba
sobre los combates desde las posiciones
rebeldes a su llegada a francia le
sorprendieron los hechos que eran
noticia decidió entonces relatar los
eventos de su nuevo mundo
cuando llegue al francés 2018
las manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos eran la noticia principal
luego en 2020 viene el confinamiento
entonces tomé fotos
locales porque quería que los demás
supieran que soy periodista yo que sigo
siendo reportero gráfico y que quiero
continuar mi carrera aquí
una manera también de enviar noticias a
su familia que sigue en siria